one of the things we've been talking
about for some time is the republican
party has completely given up on policy
they just they don't even talk about
policy anymore sometimes it sort of
sounds like maybe they're approximating
what might be considered policy but it's
essentially just cultural issues but i
have for you today
a supposed policy platform this is from
republican senator rick scott who
published an 11 point
plan
to quote
rescue america it's delusional depraved
and disgusting and dangerous
and we're going to take a look at what
is on this plan and you will very
quickly see that for the most part this
is just cultural nonsense
masquerading as policy we won't spend a
ton of time on each point but i'll give
you a sense of what they are
point one our kids will say the pledge
of allegiance salute the flag learn that
america is a great country and choose
the school that best fits them
that all together
is an attack on funding of public
schools in favor of charter voucher type
programs
continued opposition to letting teachers
determine how best to teach their
students and
this cultural imposition of salute the
flag
say the pledge of allegiance this is
cultural nonsense masquerading as policy
number two the government will never
again ask american citizens to disclose
their wraith as race ethnicity or skin
color on government forms
they want you to think that those
questions can only be racist or can only
be for wokeness but the reality is that
collecting that information in so many
different ways
allows us to see
whether there are groups
being discriminated against not
necessarily
uh
openly
but
in practice and implicitly and it's
really important that we have that data
we're not looking to use it in the way
republicans claim it should be used but
if you don't collect that data you quite
literally have no idea uh uh whether
there are real inequalities along the
lines of uh race ethnicity and skin
color that we might want to address we
can't even have that conversation if you
don't collect the data okay number three
the soft on crime days of chronic
coddling criminal behavior will end
we will refund the police remember the
police hasn't been defunded and as a
national or state policy these decisions
are basically made at the municipality
level there are some municipalities who
have made changes to we will bring in
social workers or we might not replace
all the police cars right now or
whatever the police have not been
defunded in any systemic way and it's
simply another one of these cultural
issues
okay
number four
and these are kind of all over the map
four we will secure our border finish
building the wall and name it after
president donald trump the wall is
obviously not getting built the wall is
also not the solution to our immigration
problem it's a distraction and naming it
after trump another one of these virtue
signaling nonsense claims
we will grow america's economy starve
washington's economy and stop socialism
so this is an argument number one
against non-existent socialism another
cultural battle that they are fighting
and
code for we will cut social welfare
programs number six we will eliminate
all federal programs that can be done
locally
and enact term limits for federal
bureaucrats in congress term limits i'm
actually open to
but again eliminating all federal
programs that can be done locally a lot
of programs can be done locally but it
doesn't make any sense to and that's
another way to simply cut welfare number
seven we will protect the integrity of
american democracy and stop left-wing
efforts to rig elections straight up
projection
trump tried stealing the election
and they are now just projecting that on
to the left
total
nonsense cultural war issue number eight
we will protect defend and promote the
american family at all costs saying the
nuclear family is crucial to
civilization that can have within it
any number of homophobic
transphobic
and other disgusting aspects
number nine men are men women are women
and unborn babies are babies so both
transphobic and anti-abortion
number 10 americans will be free to
welcome god into all aspects of our
lives
very clearly trying to take down
separation of church and state
bring prayer back to school etc etc and
number 11 we are americans not
globalists which is sort of an allusion
to this america first nationalism type
rhetoric
not a surprise that that's also
something they want to push this is a
plan guys it's an 11-point plan
nine and a half of the 11 points
are just a rehashing of the same
cultural war issues that we've seen them
play for a long time the other one and a
half are just excuses to cut welfare
that's the plan guys that's the plan
we have a situation right now where many
companies want and need to hire people
quickly
but it is difficult to find the right
candidates and workable is going to help
workable accelerates every step of your
hiring process workable helps you cast
the widest net possible by posting your
jobs to over 200 of the top job boards
with just one click it helps you
evaluate and hire quickly with modern
tools like video interviews and
e-signatures you can automate some of
those repetitive tasks like scheduling
interviews whether you're hiring for
your coffee shop or your engineering
team workable is exactly what you need
to hire the right people fast
start hiring today with a risk-free
15-day trial if you hire during the
trial which many do
it will cost you nothing
just go to workable.com
podcast to start hiring the link is down
below